[Music]
welcome
to the mit center for art science and
technology's 2021 symposium
unfolding intelligence the art and
science of contemporary computation
cast was established in 2012 with the
goal of building
and building on connections between the
worlds of art science and technology
this is the third in a series of
symposia the cast has convened since
then and as with its predecessors
we bring together artists scientists
engineers and humanists
from within mit and from the world at
large to discuss areas of rapidly
evolving research and urgent social
relevance
and defined in that dialogue stimulation
confirmation
provocation intersection and we hope
common purpose at mit
cast partners with departments labs and
centers to integrate the arts across the
curriculum
to enrich and encourage artistic
collaboration and to provide support to
faculty and members of the mit community
as they pursue their own artistic
practice and or research
in addition to symposia like this cass
facilitates the sharing of this creative
work beyond the institute
by producing concerts exhibitions and
publications
and making them available to the public
so thank you for being with us today we
hope you will join us throughout the
week at virtual events addressing the
aesthetic
technical and critical issues pertaining
to artificial intelligence
and computational media we also look
forward to seeing you
on friday april 9th as the symposium
culminates
with a live interactive event to which
all attendees are invited
and which you can join presenters and
artists in breakout rooms
to explore hidden threads between all
that has been discussed
this week
welcome my name is caroline jones and
i'm an art historian
teaching in the history theory criticism
section
of the department of architecture here
at mit
this is a pre-recorded introduction to
the second of two sessions
on the theme of open systems in the
unfolding intelligence symposium hosted
by the center for art science and
technology known as cast
these sessions are also supported by
mit's transmedia storytelling
initiative once again i want to thank
mellon postdoc will lockett
and cast director leela kinney for
making this symposium a reality
as well as catherine higgins who served
as the open systems
session producer please feel free to ask
questions at any time during the webcast
you'll also find links to other events
in the symposium our colleagues at the
list visual arts center
have their own hosted of related events
on artists and ai that i hope you can
sign up for
and attend i want to begin
my brief introduction tonight by
speaking the words of mit's
recently achieved land acknowledgement
although we gather virtually the
resources
and capacities of mit come from being a
land-grant university
based on the ongoing occupation and
colonization
of previously occupied land
mit acknowledges indigenous peoples
as the traditional stewards of this land
recognizing
the enduring relationship that exists
between them
and their traditional territories the
land on which we gather
is the traditional unseated territory of
the wampanoag nation
among others we acknowledge the painful
history of genocide
and the forced occupation of their
territory and we honor and respect
the many diverse indigenous people
connected to this land
from time immemorial
acknowledging the living indigenous
communities here in massachusetts
is really important to me and this
evening's session
opens directly onto questions of
indigenous epistemologies of kinship
and biological theories of mutualism
that our panelists will discuss
following their pre-recorded
presentations we'll engage in a live
discussion
and q a mutualism emerges from professor
fredrickson's
biological study of entangled ecologies
while professor lewis argues that kinfip
can also be forged
with our machine learning prostheses
potentially as proxies
for other species with whom we share the
planet
the way that both of them utilize
computation
and think about the promise of ai is the
fascinating conversation i look forward
to engaging them with tonight
we'll begin with professor fredrickson
followed by professor lewis i'll then
open out our discussion
to your synchronous questions and
answers
megan frederickson has been engaged with
the biology of social insects
plants and their symbionts for decades
educated at harvard as an undergrad
she did her phd at stanford and runs a
lab on mutualism
ecology and evolution at the university
of toronto
frederiksen's work on mutualism and its
role in driving evolution
requires that biological events be
converted into data
data that might be necessary to convince
remnant darwinists obsessed with
survival of the fittest
predicated on individual reproductive
success
that we actually need to think about
other units of evolutionary fitness
and combinations of communities that
evolve together
while field analysis alone might inform
us about native and invasive ants
as seed spreaders for example
we need rapid throughput genomic
analysis to tell us about
holobionts and hologenomes in these
complex plant
animal societies megan is writing a book
that aims to synthesize mutualism in
microbiome research
in order to better understand when and
which microbes are beneficial to their
hosts
including humans and how we can make the
most of microbes
which are everywhere on this planet so
for those at yenisothila's talk this
morning
you'll recognize a consistent troubling
of the cranial model of intelligence
that idea that a brain can be analogized
to a centralized computer
mainframe or motherboard with its
circuits
and command centers sutula and
frederickson
both point to the fact that there is
intelligence in the microbial gut brain
that we are still trying to figure out
there's also intelligence in the immune
brain
that learns and remembers from its
encounters with vaccines and viruses
there is super organismic intelligence
in the ant colony
and even a kind of homeostatic
intelligence in our beleaguered
planetary systems
frederickson is building a laboratory
system that wants to engage these
questions
quite precisely she hopes to do
massively parallel host microbe
experiments in hopes of testing the
effects of thousands of microbial
communities
along with their mutualist symbionts
this is important
when we assess the impact of termites on
the african ecology for example
we need to reckon with the fact that
these youth social insects
don't even have the capacity to digest
wood
in their guts without symbiotic protests
carried along they form lifelong
relationships with
quite different species that must evolve
with them
and are responsible for managing an
ecosystem dependent on their activities
by naming this session open systems i
aimed precisely to open ideas of
intelligence to this kind of questioning
the broader conversation about models of
sentience
and ways of knowing among and between
planetary forms
fredrickson uses genetic analysis and
thinks with algorithms
to trace evolutionary changes among
mutualists in an ecosystem
such as a recent paper about this
caribbean plant known as the yellow
alder
crucial to a particular butterfly the
tawny oster
which raises eggs on this particular
plant's leaf
the evolution of mating and reproductive
systems involve all members
of this mutual relationship confronting
the tendency of biologists
to speak of parasites and hosts or talk
about
cheaters and altruists frederick's lab
offers a recent study of rhizobial
bacteria genomics
inside legume roots and she will discuss
in her pre-recorded presentation
she and her colleagues showed that the
evolution of bacteria
lines solicited by these legumes is what
drives the evolutionary outcome
of the mutualist system bacteria confer
fitness on the legumes and evolve toward
greater mutualism
not less bacteria are crucially
part of the environment which also is a
partner in this dynamic
although frederickson acknowledges that
the classical biological definition of
kinship
did not allow her to call these
symbiotic mutualisms of legumes
and their bacteria kinship
maybe this symposium will encourage her
to persuade biology otherwise
think how useful such a concept could be
in describing a situation
in which a nitrogen-starved plant sends
out a chemical signal for help
growing nodules on its roots to welcome
the necessary
nitrogen-fixing bacteria from the
environment
in one recent analysis by biochemist
mirati and condorosi
exchanges of signal molecules between
the partners
bacteria and legume leads to the
formation of root nodules
where bacteria are converted to nitrogen
fixing fixing
bacterioids in other words the bacteria
change from free dwelling in the soil to
endosymbionts
in their new dependency on the legume
for photosynthesized nutrition
jason edward lewis understands the power
of
non-sanguinean kinships he brings into
this discussion an acute awareness of
tech traditional environmental knowledge
in confrontation with our western models
of technocratic mastery
prec produces an active link with the
teaching of elders and ancestors
which lewis recently celebrated in his
native hawaii
and as it is recently being reevaluated
in something like the controlled burns
of the california high dry lands
those were originally conducted by first
peoples dismissed by western management
techniques
and are now being re-solicited to manage
those fragile
lands like frederickson lewis was also
educated at stanford
where he received a degree in symbolic
systems before going to the royal
college of arts
for an mphil degree in design professor
lewis is both a creative coder and a
media artist
he has also been a profound mentor of
generations
of indigenous media theorists and
artists professor of computation
a professor of computation arts and
university research chair in
computational media
here also runs the initiative for
indigenous futures
from his post at concordia university
in all these endeavors lewis has given
us
an entirely new and fruitful way of
thinking about ken
notably in his collaborative polemic
published in mit's own journal
of design and science making ken with
the machines
the authors who identify variously as
kri bakota
and hawaiian hold that many different
indigenous epistemologies
converge on methods for making
respectful relationships
with minerals microbes and machines
as well as animals of course giving us
forms of knowing
that can help us move away from the
anthropocentric troubles we
find ourselves in as a scholar of
hawaiian
cherokee and samoan descent himself
lewis puts these epistemologies to work
in his own creative computational
poetics
i'm showing you here an excerpt from his
poem quartet
which draws on the 2019 science fiction
book by adrian tchaikovsky
children of ruin about an octopoid
intelligence
on a terraformed planet lewis's poem
segues into an imagining of a troika of
ai
companions based on the intelligence
of the honorable octopus put at the
service of a young hawaiian adolescent
in addition to stimulating lewis poetry
this ako akamai ai is in tune with
deeply held hawaiian
concepts of responsibility and
reciprocity within the ecosystem
these poems and meditations are
published within a document lewis edited
in 2019
uh and published in 2020 the indigenous
protocol for ai
an ip for thinking about the potentials
and colonizing perils
of artificial intelligence the document
was the pre-coveted achievement
of an extraordinary gathering
of scholars and thinkers including our
own esteemed colleague defox harrell
who's running a different session in
this symposium
these critical approaches to ip and ai
want to open
out those systems to our scrutiny as
well as welcoming our multi-generational
and multi-species imagination
in conclusion if this morning's
conversation prompted artist yana
suthula and curator theorist lars
banglarsen
to think about ai as alien intelligence
addressing how we might imagine
potential kinds of sentience
in our planets not yet encountered then
this evening's prompts us to think about
ai
as kin frederickson and then lewis
will help us unfold machine intelligence
as a tool for revealing mutualisms
and a creative device for creating more
than human alliances
let us turn then to these amazing
panelists for their open systems
engaging life and machines thank you
hi everyone my name is megan
frederickson
and i'm a professor of ecology and
evolutionary biology
at the university of toronto my talk
today is entitled
animal plant and microbial life
interconnected
so i study mutualism and symbiosis
two words that are often used
interchangeably
but are not actually synonyms so
symbiosis means
different species living together in
close association
like corals and their microscopic
photosynthetic
algae or leguminous plants and the
nitrogen-fixing bacteria
they house in root nodules or grazing
mammals
and their gut microbes mutualism and
contrast
means all interactions between species
in which both species or all species
benefit from the interaction
whether or not the species actually live
together
maybe most
symbioses or probably most symbioses are
mutualisms
but not all mutualisms are symbiotic so
for example plants
and their pollinators are generally
mutually beneficial interactions
even though they don't actually live
together
and mutualisms and symbioses are
everywhere
all around us all the time these
interactions make
fundamental but often underappreciated
contributions to ecosystem functions
that sustain biodiversity
globally most pollination seed dispersal
biological nitrogen fixation
photosynthesis and coral reefs
and digestion in in mammalian guts
happens mutualistically
humans also have both symbionts and
mutualists
we live in close association with the
diverse
microorganisms that colonize our bodies
especially
our guts sometimes this community of
microorganisms is called
the human microbiome which is currently
a hot area of research
in biology and we can also think
about the interactions that humans have
with
crops or with livestock as mutualisms in
which both
both species benefit so this is my son
actually picking strawberries
in a farm at a farm last summer
but i don't really study humans in fact
i don't even study vertebrates
i study plants and insects and microbes
which are far more diverse on our planet
than vertebrates are
and my research aims to understand how
mutualisms and symbiosis links the fate
of interacting species in ecosystems
and how these interconnections between
species have shaped the evolution of
life on
earth so mutualism is a form of
cooperation
and cooperation is an extremely
widespread phenomenon
at all levels of biological organization
we can think of genes cooperating in
genomes
organelles cooperating in cells cells
cooperating in multicellular bodies
and individuals cooperating in societies
including our own
and mutualism is just cooperation
between
species
it's also so widespread that most plants
and animals engage in mutualism
with at least one other species that
they depend on for
nutrition or protection or dispersal
and i study mutualism and symbiosis in
the wild
working at field stations in both the
peruvian amazon
and here in canada and elsewhere and i
also bring
insects and plants and microbes into my
lab at the university of toronto
to study their traits or their behaviors
or their genes in ways that would be
impossible in the field
and increasingly like many other
biologists i also use
computational and bioinformatic methods
to quantify patterns
in larger complex data sets i'm showing
you some video
of one interaction that i've studied for
many years between an amazonian plant
and the ants that it feeds and houses
so each branch on this tree has a hollow
swelling like the one you can see in the
middle
those leaves in the video and if you
were to cut open
that hollow swelling on the branches on
this tree
you would find them full of ants and
their eggs and larvae
and this tree species has actually
evolved to make
this specialized form of housing for
ants
and it also makes these tiny little food
bodies which are too small to see in the
video
but it makes them to feed the ant
colonies that live inside its branches
why well these ants may be small
but they are aggressive and have a
really powerful sting
and they attack any herbivores that land
on the plant
including this grasshopper that you can
see in the video or what's left of it
anyways
so the ants defend the plant against the
plant's enemies and the plant
nourishes and shelters the ants an
excellent example of cooperation between
species
but cooperation is supposed to have a
dark side
cooperation in all its forms is supposed
to break down because of the evolution
of selfish cheating strategies
evolutionary biologists think about a
population
of cooperators which are shown here in
the slide in the blue seas
and these cooperators these blue seas
benefit
others in their population at some
short-term cost
to themselves but they recruit that
short-term cost
by also receiving benefits from other
cooperators in their population
but imagine if there was a new genotype
the red d here
that arises by mutation in this
population
and what what makes the red d genotype
different
is that it no longer provides any
benefits to the other members
of the population and thus it saves on
the short-term costs of cooperation
but the red d's still receive benefits
from others in the population
and thus have higher fitness than the
cooperators than the blue seas
because they get all of the same
benefits but pay none of the costs
thus the red d is a cheater or defector
genotype that is favored by natural
selection
and we predict it should spread in the
population
if all else is equal which it never is
we would therefore expect
that the red d genotype would spread to
fixation
and we would have started with a
population of cooperators
the blue seas and ended with a
population
of non-cooperators the red d's
in other words we would expect
cooperation to break down
given enough time so why do we still
observe cooperation in all its glorious
forms
throughout nature how cooperation
evolves and is maintained in nature
despite the threat of selfish cheating
is a question with a very long history
in evolutionary biology
and i'm not really going to have time in
my 15-minute talk today to do it justice
but very briefly we have known for a
long time
that this puzzle is solved if the donor
and the recipient of the cooperation
are related meaning they share genes
the british geneticist jbs haldane
is said to have remarked that he would
not give up his own life
to save one brother but he would lay
down his life
for two brothers or eight cousins why
because in humans siblings share on
average
half their genes and first cousins share
on average an
eighth the idea that cooperation evolved
that cooperation can evolve
if it's directed at relatives or kin
was further formalized by wd hamilton in
1964
in a pair of foundational papers and
it's still one of the leading
explanations
for how cooperation evolves between
individuals of the same species
for example in bees and ants and other
insects that live in colonies
as well as in humans but it doesn't work
for mutualisms
mutualisms by definition occur between
members of different species
and are thus not kin thus hamilton's
explanation for the evolution of
cooperation
which is often known as kin selection
cannot explain
the evolution of mutualism
nonetheless mutualism and symbiosis
clearly evolve and persist in nature
they're all over the place when we look
around the natural world
and my research has repeatedly shown
that mutualism
oh sorry the cheating does not threaten
mutualism evolution
i wrote an opinion article a few years
ago entitled mutualisms are not on the
verge of breakdown
arguing that despite a lot of attention
to the cheater problem
we rarely actually see cheaters in
nature and there is little evidence that
mutualisms
break down into parasitisms over
evolutionary time
in short mutualisms don't go over to the
dark side
moreover there are reasons to think that
the evolution of mutualism and symbiosis
actually generates new life forms and
new functions that can lead to
ecological and evolutionary success
so to give just one example the
eukaryotic cell
is the product of an ancient symbiosis
and of course this new kind of cell
gave rise to all the plants and animals
and fungi
that are on the planet today as lynn
margulis and dorian sagan once wrote
life did not take over the globe by
combat but by networking
so i want to briefly describe one recent
research project from my lab
to give you the flavor of the kind of
work that i do and also to convince you
that cooperation can evolve easily and
fast
so this project involves the legume
rhizobium symbiosis
shown in cartoon form on this slide
leguminous plants
including many that you are familiar
with like soybeans
have symbiotic bacteria called rhizobia
that live inside
nodules on their roots those little uh
circles on the roots are the nodules
that house these symbiotic bacteria
and all plants need nitrogen and there's
lots and lots of nitrogen in the air
but it's in a form that plants can't use
for growth
but rhizobia and some other bacteria are
capable of doing something really
special they can take
nitrogen from the air and turn it into
plant accessible forms
a process called nitrogen fixation and
if
of course plants can do something
special that a lot of bacteria can't do
and that is they can photosynthesize and
they can take carbon dioxide from the
air
and turn it into sugar which bacteria
also need
so legumes and rhizobia form a symbiosis
in which they exchange
plant fixed carbon and bacteria fixed
nitrogen to their mutual benefit
this is economically and ecologically
important because there are many crops
and forage plants that are symbiotic
legumes
and because biological nitrogen fixation
done by bacteria
is really critical to nutrient cycling
in ecosystems
so in my lab uh we've done a lot of work
on how
in the wild there's lots of variation
among
rhizobia in how much nitrogen they can
fix and how much they help their plants
grow
and we wanted to find out whether we
could evolve better symbionts in the lab
so we took rhizobia and added them to
sterile plants and allowed them to grow
and when the plants got big enough
we cut off the above ground plant parts
so the leaves and the stems
and let the roots die and re-release
bacteria into the soil
then we planted another seed of the same
type of plant
and repeated this process five times in
a greenhouse experiment lasting about a
year
we used five different plant genotypes
you can think of plant genotypes as
different varieties of the same species
of plant
always giving the bacteria a new seed of
the same plant type
and at the end of the experiment we
isolated and cultured the microbes
uh tested them on new host plants and
then measured how many nodules they
formed and how much they helped plants
to grow
so this is what the experiment looked
like in the greenhouse with bacteria
evolving in those
pots of soil beneath all those little
legumes
and this is what we found so each one of
these panels labeled with a number
across the top
is a different plant genotype or variety
and we tested
the bacteria at the end of the
experiment both on the plant genotype
that they evolved on
in the greenhouse experiment and on all
the other kinds of plant genotypes which
they hadn't seen during their
year-long evolution in the greenhouse
and that's indicated on the x-axis
as whether the bacteria shared
evolutionary history
with their host so the left-hand panel
shows how much the bacteria helped
plants to grow how large the plants grew
with different kinds of bacteria
the right-hand panel shows how many
nodules those bacteria formed on plants
and what i can hope what i hope you can
see is that in general bacteria formed
more
nodules and made plants grow bigger when
they had evolved with that planet
plant genotype for a year so the
microbes got
better at cooperating with plants they
became better mutualists but only with
the host they were paired with
during the year-long evolution
experiment
so i've just shown you that we can
evolve better symbionts in the lab
we can make microbes that are more
cooperative with their hosts
and one current big idea in the field is
that it might be possible to evolve
or engineer microbial symbionts for a
wide range of beneficial
purposes be those applications in health
or in agriculture or in biodiversity
conservation
maybe we can design microbial strains or
communities that improve
human or or ecosystem health or
well-being
but the main problem is that microbes
are not in fact machines
they are living organisms that do not
just stay where you put them
they do not necessarily work in
predictable ways or as the designer
intended they disperse they jump from
one house to another
and they evolve so i think the jury is
still out on whether
evolving or engineering microbiomes will
really work
as some have envisioned so what does
this all mean for artificial
intelligence i haven't really said much
about ai today
and i am no ai expert but i will say
this in my area of biology
we often think about microbes behaving
according to simple algorithms and
evolving and interacting
in tiny experimental microcosms
as just one step removed from a
simulation model running on a computer
microbes in the lab add only a little
bit of realism
above what happens in silico and they
are still a far cry
from the complexity of real natural
ecosystems
so in my lab we spend a lot of time
thinking about what conditions and
designs
select for cooperation among beings that
don't share
genes and when if ever we would expect
to see the evolution of selfishness
or cheating and this seems like also a
worthwhile question to ponder
as humans design and create ever more
intelligent machines and with that i'd
like to acknowledge the people
institutions and funders that have
supported my recent research
and i look forward to the discussion
hello everybody i want to start by
thanking the organizers for inviting me
to this panel
and to dr jones in particular for
moderating and bringing
megan and i together for preliminary
conversation
i am speaking from jojage known in
settler canada as montreal
on the traditional territory of the
ghaniaga nation
i want to preface these brief comments
by noting that
as i use the term indigenous i'm talking
specifically of a north american pacific
islander
and australia and new zealand context
and i want to underline that i'm not
here to speak on behalf of any
indigenous peoples
but rather to report on the work that my
indigenous colleagues and i have been
doing
today i'm going to talk about the work
of the indigenous protocol and
artificial intelligence working group
for me that story starts with making kin
with the machines
an article i co-wrote in 2018 with three
colleagues
noelani arista a historian who was based
at the university of hawaii at the time
archer pachaues a cree performance
artist who's based in toronto
and suzanne kite a lakota phd candidate
who works with me
our goal was to try to understand what
artificial intelligence
might mean within our particular
indigenous context
in the essay we write we believe that
indigenous epistemologies
are much better at respectfully
accommodating the non-human
we retain a sense of community that is
articulated through complex kin networks
anchored in specific territories
genealogies and protocols
ultimately our goal is that we as a
species figure out how to treat these
new non-human kin
respectfully and reciprocally
one way to think about this is to
understand that each of our cultures
hawaiian cree and lakota
when confronted with a new entity asks
first how are you related to me
rather than what is that that is true
for other humans certainly but also
animals stones mountains and oceans that
first question illustrates a view of the
world that sees all encounters through a
relational lens
first even before essence and certainly
before utility
how each of our cultures articulates
that relationality is expressed through
protocol in other words the procedures
for recognizing and maintaining those
relationships
protocol is very important within our
cultures
as it guides us in how to live a good
life for instance hawaiians understand
themselves as links in a genealogical
chain
that places us in a kinship relationship
with the ocean and the creatures of sea
and land
as dr arista writes kanaka mali
ontologies make it difficult and
outright unrewarding to reduce pono or
balance
to a measure of one to prioritize the
benefit of
individuals over relationships healthy
and fruitful balance requires
multiplicity and a willingness to
continually think in
and through relation even when perhaps
particularly when
engaging with those different from
ourselves a kanaka mali approach to
understanding ai might
seek to attend to the power or mana that
is exchanged and shared between ai and
humans
in attending to questions of mana i
emphasize our preference for reciprocity
and relationship building
that take the pono here meaning good or
benefit
take the pono of those in relation into
consideration
uh cree people situate everything in a
circle relationships as mr pachalus
writes
in cree epistemology relationship is
paramount
nehion or plane's cree language divides
everything into two primary categories
animate and inanimate
one is not better than the other there
are merely different states of being
these categories are flexible certain
toys are inanimate until a child is
playing with them
during which time they are animate a
record player is considered animate
while a record radio or television set
is inanimate but animate or inanimate
all things have a place in our circle of
kinship or waco to win
stones exemplify the complex set of
protocols that govern how the lakota
approach can ship with the non-human
ms kite writes standing cloud or bill
stover
communicates lakota ethics and ontology
through speaking about the interiority
of stones
these ancestors that i have in my hand
are going to speak through me so that
you will understand the things that they
see happening in this world and the
things that they know
to help all people stones are considered
ancestors
stones actively speak stones speak
through and to
humans stones see and know most
importantly stones want to help
the agency of stones connects directly
to the question of ai
as ais form not only from code but from
materials of the earth
to remove the concept of ai from its
materiality is to sever this connection
in forming a relationship to ai we form
a relationship to the minds
and the stones
if all things might potentially be a
relation this certainly includes the
tools we make
in the field of ai we are crafting
systems whose goal is to be human-like
in
intelligence to which we are giving
agency we've
previously only given to humans which
are being used to assess human behavior
and in some cases make judgments about
that behavior and which
on the outside edge of the science
fiction dream may achieve some form of
sentience
maybe even consciousness these are
systems in which we already are
in relation and that relationship is
only going to grow and become more
complex as the technology advances
indigenous cultures have tools languages
protocols and epistemologies
that remain robust in articulating these
types of relationships
as the making kin with the machines
essay was being written i work with two
other colleagues angie abdullah a troll
woolway designer based in sydney
and oev parker jones a hawaiian
neuroscientist working at oxford
we put together two workshops in the
winter and spring of 2019.
these are called the indigenous protocol
and ai workshops and they are attended
by 35 participants
with representation from 15 indigenous
communities from across ao to roa
australia north america and the pacific
one of the unfolding intelligences
organizers
dr fox harrell and his graduate student
danielle olson were among those who
joined us to lend
their good minds the group included
neuroscientists cultural knowledge
holders computer scientists poets
language keepers visual artists hula
teachers venture capitalists historians
software engineers
language keepers and others the workshop
conversation covered extensive ground
including epistemology cultural
protocols machine learning colonization
temporal models
ontology sentience versus consciousness
software architectures
and linguistics
out of those conversations came the
indigenous protocol and ai position
paper which we published in july of 2020
indigenous epistemologies generally
approach the discovery refinement
transmission and preservation of
knowledge
as inherently multi-disciplinary as such
the position paper features artistic
excursions
as well as analytical essays and poetry
as well as profiles of prototypes built
during the workshops
here's a small sampling suzanne kite
mentioned previously wrote a chapter
called how to build anything ethically
she examines the protocol her people
that lakota use to build sweat lodges
in order to develop a methodology for
building computational systems
in a good way
michelle brown is another phd student
who works for us
from the university of hawaii at manoa
she wrote a chapter on how she imagines
her indigenous basque community harness
harnessing ai to support them
in their relationships with the ocean
given the centrality of the eel to her
culture she designed the technology to
mimic
eel behavior creating the chi chardon
ocean going ai relative
one of my contributions is to imagine a
young hawaiian growing up alongside
three different ai systems
one is modeled after process-oriented
indigenous languages such as blackfoot
as described by
leroy little bear one takes its
foundation in hawaiian epistemologies of
abundance
and the third uses the neural
architecture of an octopus to translate
between the first two and advise the
youth
we also had a project that prototyped a
piece of indigenous design language
translation software
noah arista caroline running wolf
michael running wolf caleb moses and
joel davidson
worked together to create hua ki e an
app that allows you to use your camera
phone to look at objects in your
environment and get community verified
hawaiian language descriptions of them
and dr hemi wanga wrote about the
potential for ai systems and related
technologies to be used against
indigenous peoples
as an extension of colonial practices of
exploitation
extraction and control particularly
those that displace a people's
understanding of themselves with a world
view that favors the colonizer
he writes the colonization of the
culture language and mind takes place
through the transmission of mental
habits and contents by means of social
systems
other than the colonial structure these
social systems include cultural
practices language
and technologies such as artificial
intelligence
we also developed guidelines for
indigenous centered ai design to reflect
in condensed form
the themes and concerns that we found
most important
i want to highlight several of those
themes
relationality and its consequence
reciprocity are the core of humanness
and how we produce knowledge that is
worth knowing ai systems should be
designed to understand how humans and
non-humans are related
to and interdependent on each other
understanding supporting formalizing and
encoding these relationships is a
primary design goal
indigenous knowledge is often rooted in
specific territories
ai systems should be designed
hyperlocally meaning in partnership with
specific indigenous communities
and should be responsible to those
communities provide relevant support and
be accountable to those communities
first and foremost
and finally all ai systems should be
designed to respect and support data
sovereignty
indigenous communities must control how
their data is solicited collected
analyzed and operationalized
they decide when to protect it and when
to share it
where the cultural intellectual property
rights reside or if they even want to
deal with that sort of framework and to
whom those rights adhere
so i want to close with two provocations
that grow out of this work
the ai industrial complex doesn't have
an ethics problem it has an epistemology
problem
the persistent infections of bias are
simply symptoms of this deeper issue
the epistemology problem stems from a
series of assumptions that are built
into how we design and deploy our
computational systems
the user is an individual the individual
is primarily concerned with maximizing
their personal well-being
culture is a second order affect rather
than the primary phenomenon
and that the only useful knowledge is
that produced through rational
instrumentality
this makes ai system engineers blind to
important aspects of human existence
such as trust care and community that
are fundamental to how human
intelligence
actually operates the refusal to engage
explore and operationalize knowledge
frameworks that centralize these aspects
is a tremendous scientific failing
creating huge gaps between what humans
think of as an intelligent presence in
the world
and what the industry academic complex
is building
this to me is the cause of white the
white supremacy that social and computer
scientists
such as noble benjamin gabriel and bulan
mini have documented the bias in these
systems is not a bug
but rather a feature of an interlocking
set of knowledge systems designed over
centuries to privilege
white men we need to be clear about this
furthermore i have to wonder if machine
learning deep learning and all the
different ai techniques that rely on
vast amounts of data to work
are not fundamentally ethically
compromised
very little of that data was collected
in a truly ethical manner
the people who produced that data were
not asked if it be used this way
they were not compensated for this use
and the use most likely does not benefit
them directly
indigenous people have a long history
with people like this
scientists who behave as if our data is
a publicly available resource that they
can use to make themselves famous or
wealthy or powerful
all in the name of the greater good of
increasing humanity's store of knowledge
indigenous folks see people like that
coming a mile away
and recognize them from what they are
colonizers
ai system builders who do not understand
the cultures in which they operate
cannot understand how their systems
actually perform
as scientists they should be ashamed at
how narrow-minded they are
as engineers they should be embarrassed
at how badly their technology fits their
use case
we should expect more from them
in the meanwhile my colleagues and i
will continue building capacity within
our communities so that we can design
and build ai systems ourselves
that are better suited to helping our
particular communities thrive
ones that look beyond impoverished
models of intelligence to develop ones
that are based
on abundance
thank you i am looking forward to the
conversation